♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
The White House announced on
Friday that President Biden had
a cancerous skin lesion removed
from his chest.
And the lesion is already
running two points ahead
of DeSantis.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
attended CPAC over the weekend
and told reporters he would not
drop out of the 2024 election
if he's indicted on criminal
charges.
You know, we compare him
to a mobster all the time,
but now he's literally saying,
"No problem,
I can still run things
from the joint."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech over
the weekend at CPAC,
former President Trump
said that before he came along,
the Republican Party was run
by freaks and fools.
Yeah. Nothing like the
Rhodes scholars we have today.
That's like going to Orlando
and saying, "You know,
it wasn't always this nice."
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump Jr.'s
fiancee Kimberly Guilfoyle spoke
over the weekend at CPAC, and
it looked like a rousing speech
until they cut to the audience.
Take a look.
-All of us in this room have
one message to Joe Biden --
it is time to put America first!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Which brings us to a segment
called "Where is Everybody?!"
♪♪
Where is everybody?
I've never seen a theater
that empty, and I used to do
long-form improv.
[ Laughter ]
I've been in elevators more
crowded than that.
Where is there --
Did they accidentally schedule
you against Kid Rock karaoke?
That speech must have taken
twice as long
just to account for the echo.
Speaking of,
why are you yelling?
It's not like you need to play
to the back of the house.
And what's this,
"All of us in the room
have one message for Joe Biden"?
You're the only one there.
There couldn't be a second
message in the room
for Joe Biden.
If anything, that room
has one message for you --
bring it way down.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been...
-It's a hit.
It's a hit new segment.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
spoke yesterday
at the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library.
Specifically, he said,
"All these gotta go."
[ Laughter ]
TV host Rachael Ray has
announced she's ending
her talk show after 17 seasons.
She made the decision in less
than 30 minutes,
but at home,
it would take you two hours.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't do great.
Better than I thought
it would do.
So that's kind --
I'm not saying it's a win-win.
It was definitely a win-lose,
but...
A woman in Florida recently set
a Guinness World Record
by winning 23 ultramarathons
in 23 days.
In less happy news, her car
is basically undrivable now.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, United Airlines has
announced it will offer
T-Mobile customers free Wi-Fi
on all flights,
and Spirit announced that
they're gonna fly really close,
and you should be able to hop on
their network.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Good Photoshop.
President Biden published
an op-ed today
in The New York Times
and that man is spiraling.
[ Laughter ]
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
last night claimed
that the security camera footage
from the Capitol attack
"does not show an insurrection
or a riot in progress."
Yeah, okay,
but when you cherry-pick
the footage you're showing,
you can prove whatever you want.
I could show you footage
from "John Wick"
that proves he's not violent.
Take a look.
-[ Whining ]
[ Laughter ]
-We'll grab you
some kibble later.
[ Tender tune plays ]
[ Collar rings against bowl ]
-You're telling me that guy
[ Laughter ]
is a trained killer?
Give me a break!
[ Laughter ]
The footage doesn't lie.
After Fox News
host Tucker Carlson
aired exclusive security footage
from the Capitol attack,
former President Trump posted
on Truth Social,
"LET THE JANUARY 6
PRISONERS GO."
You guys know we can see
what you're doing, right?
Kevin McCarthy,
who is Trump's Waylon Smithers,
[ Laughter ]
gives all the footage
to Tucker;
Tucker shows
only the tame parts;
and then Trump claims
the rioters were framed.
It's like watching a magic show
where the magician
is wearing sheer sleeves.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They do have very nice sheer
sleeves on the magician.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't know how
it was going to look.
I find out with you guys.
It's the best way
to do quality control.
[ Laughter ]
In a new episode of her podcast,
former First Lady
Michelle Obama said
that she sobbed uncontrollably
for 30 minutes
after leaving the White House
at the end
of President Obama's term.
As opposed to her husband,
who dealt
with his post-presidency grief
more stoically.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Columbia University last week
announced it will no longer
require SAT or ACT scores
in undergraduate admissions,
while UMass announced
that you no longer need
that show-and-tell project.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Massachusetts' own
Mike Scollins.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Transportation Secretary
Pete Buttigieg
pushed back against critics
characterizing him
as being elitist
and out of touch
and said his critics,
"wouldn't know their way
around a T.J.Maxx
if their life depended on it."
[ Laughter ]
But if you're lost
inside a T.J.Maxx,
your life does depend on it.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Pete Buttigieg said,
"You think Tucker Carlson
knows the difference
between a T.J.Maxx
and a Kohl's?"
Actually, he might,
because aren't those his sons?
[ As Carlson ]
T.J.Maxx, Kohl!
[ Laughter ]
It's time for lacrosse practice.
Let's go!
[ Laughter ]
Grocery delivery service
Hello Fresh confirmed yesterday
it will stop selling
coconut milk from Thailand
over concerns
of forced monkey labor.
From now on, they're only going
to use union monkeys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A group of entrepreneurs
in Massachusetts
have filed paperwork to open
a topless marijuana dispensary,
[ Oohs ]
though they might run
into some legal issues,
since they're ten.
[ Laughter, ohhs, and applause ]
"Hi, we'd like to file
some papers.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we have an idea
for a business.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, can we -- can we put here,
'Don't tell our parents'?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor
of St. Patrick's Day,
Dairy Queen is offering its new
Under the Rainbow Shake,
which features
vanilla soft serve
and multicolored sprinkles.
And Arby's is honoring
St. Paddy's Day
by driving all the snakes
out of the kitchen.
The White House said yesterday
that it supports
a new bipartisan bill
that would give President Biden
the power to ban TikTok.
Of course, Biden could end
TikTok at any time
simply by making an account.
Ugh, okay.
This jumped the shark.
[ Laughter ]
Capitol Police Chief
Thomas Manger
issued a statement yesterday
criticizing Fox host
Tucker Carlson's release
of security footage
from the January 6th attack
and said Carlson made "offensive
and misleading conclusions."
Of course,
that's just what it says
when you turn on
his closed captioning.
[ Laughter ]
According to newly released
legal documents,
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
told colleagues
after the 2020 election,
"We are very, very close
to being able to ignore Trump
most nights.
I truly can't wait.
I hate him passionately."
Wait, wait, are you telling me
Tucker Carlson
is secretly sane?
[ Laughter ]
I would feel so betrayed
if I was a Fox viewer.
This is like
if you joined a cult,
sold all your belongings,
shaved your head,
moved to the desert,
and then it turns out
the cult leader is just, like...
a Methodist.
[ Laughter ]
Voters in Oklahoma
rejected a measure yesterday
to legalize the recreational use
of marijuana.
Apparently, time already moves
slowly enough in Oklahoma.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
reportedly sent a letter
to President Biden
requesting that he allow
tennis star Novak Djokovic
to enter the country to play
in the Miami Open tournament.
That story again --
Ron DeSantis begs Biden
to open the border.
[ Laughter ]
After Senator Bernie Sanders
threatened to subpoena him,
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
has agreed to testify
before the Senate's
Health, Education, Labor
and Pensions Committee.
And much like a black coffee
from Starbucks,
this has been brewing
for a very long time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
We talk -- you know,
I'll be honest with you --
behind the scenes,
we talked a little bit.
Like, "Is that joke
gonna work at all?"
And it worked a little.
[ Laughter ]
A venti?
How do you say a little?
-Tall.
[ Laughter ]
That coffee joke
worked a tall.
[ Laughter ]
My callback didn't work a-tall.
You know what?
We're getting there.
We're getting -- We're almost --
We've almost put
a button on this.
Feel like I should have
gotten out a minute ago.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, St--
Oh, boy.
Now there's a follow-up
Starbucks joke.
[ Laughter ]
Way to keep the flow going,
Meyers.
That's right,
Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
will testify
before a Senate committee
as part of an investigation into
the chain's labor practices.
And while he's there,
they've also got some questions
about those egg bites.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Tinder recently released
an Australian edition
of its dating dictionary,
which includes the phrase
"kitten fishing."
That means
"changing aspects of yourself
to appear more attractive
to others."
Or, as we call that here,
dating.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden unveiled his new
budget today, which proposes
a 25% minimum tax on households
worth more than $100 million.
Finally, some good news for
people whose households
are worth $99 million.
[ Laughter ]
The White House
yesterday criticized
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
for his misleading portrayal
of the Capitol attack and said,
"Tucker Carlson is not
credible."
And I think they're right
because Tucker then said,
"Thank you, Mr. President,
I respect your opinion."
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis'
new book debuted this week
at the number-one spot on
The New York Times
Best-sellers List.
To be fair, everything else has
been banned.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I -- Now I see why.
Former President Trump is set
next month to publish a new book
of private letters sent to him
titled "Letters to Trump,"
though really, it's mostly final
notices from utility companies.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump is
publishing a new book titled
"Letters to Trump," and I have
to say some of them are
pretty heartbreaking.
[ Laughter ]
The CDC has launched an
investigation after more than
300 people onboard the Princess
Cruises ship Ruby Princess
fell ill during a recent voyage.
And then the investigation ended
at the word "cruises."
Yep, there's your problem.
[ Laughter ]
Federal authorities this week
charged a man with conspiracy to
commit wire fraud after he
allegedly sold
fake sports trading cards.
Said a buyer, "You mean this
isn't a real Michael Jording?"
[ Laughter ]
The Las Vegas mansion
that belonged
to the late illusionists
Siegfried and Roy
recently went up for sale
for $3 million.
It would have been $4 million,
but, you know, they had cats.
[ Laughter ]
A car recently crashed through
the window of a cafe in Houston
and narrowly missed hitting
two men who were
recording a podcast.
Nobody was injured, but sadly,
the men were able to finish
their podcast.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's available wherever you get
your podcasts.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the makers
of Hidden Valley Ranch
announced today
that they've collaborated
[ Oohs ]
with ice cream company --
[ Laughter ]
[ Tapping ]
I don't think the setup's ever
bummed people out that much.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the makers
of Hidden Valley Ranch
announced today
that they've collaborated
with ice cream company
Van Leeuwen
to offer a Hidden Valley Ranch
ice cream.
It's what people in the Midwest
are calling a salad.
You guys!
[ Laughter and applause ]
That was the monologue.
We're off and running.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]